[Music]
globally they are almost 2.1 billion
small ruminant as the Pertamina
is affecting 76 country globally and
more than a three-person modern
education of the 2.1 billion small
ruminant are in this 76 countries we
have to make sure that four infected
country we through the surveillance we
try to identify why did where the
disease when we know where the diseases
wisdom the vaccination in that area to
make sure that we reduce the incidence
of the disease so TOA eradication then
for country neighboring the infected
countries we have to make sure that we
undertake the surveillance or doing the
zone tample offer area where we'll be
doing the vaccinations and then for
infected country we try to for three
countries we try to assist them to be
recognized fear of the disease today
they are almost 53 country who are
already free of the disease now the
program will be targeting the 76 country
and then other at-risk countries and we
hope that implementing the varsity of
vaccination civilians awareness and
partnership with all the stakeholders we
are able to eradicate the disease by
2030 the vaccine is cheaper one dose of
vaccine is less than 10 cents to
vaccinate one animal is less than 50
cents the course of one chip and God is
around $100 you invest you protect with
half dollar but you gain $100 in hurt
animal but globally we try to do the
cost-benefit analysis and when you
invest $1 the return is 33.8 around $34
therefore the impact is really very high
but when the disease end
in one flock almost 80% of the flock
will die therefore the impact and if in
developing countries small ruminant is
the property of women therefore is
really major issue if a man lost his 80
over 100 animals she will not be able to
sell the animals and to have meat milk
would litter and feeble
she will not have milk for children
there for malnutrition therefore the
impact is really very high for
developing countries this the reason why
FAO and O I decided to tag that disease
for eradication for global eradication
we hope that we'll be able to achieve
the cost for the first phase first five
phase of the program is around 1 billion
but reaching that with less than 3
billion we are able to eradicate the
disease but to the cost the losses a
year of this disease due to this disease
has been estimated to be between 1.5 and
2 billion a year but if we invest 3
billion globally we eradicate the
disease